morning all police in texas have
admitted that their response to the
validation school shooting was wrong
19 children and two of their teachers
were killed while officers waited
outside the classrooms despite desperate
calls from the pupils inside
now their families are waiting for
answers about why it took so long for
police to move in our u.s correspondent
greg milam has been speaking to some of
them and sent this report
as if the grief of losing a child
weren't enough
imagine wondering if more could have
been done to save her
vincent salazar and his family are
mourning the loss of eleven-year-old
layla the baby of the family they called
her who loved tiktok and denim jackets
the families of all those who died now
waiting for answers on why it took the
police so long to confront the gunman
we're definitely going to want to know
but
right now it's hard to get answers you
know but
as time goes i'm sure we will
it's a small town i mean
i don't know
too many police forces in a small town
like this that would know how to respond
to this
i'm hoping that my daughter's death
wasn't in vain and her classmates
deaths weren't in vain and that
something does change i mean anything
anything is better than nothing
timeline of events is critical and why
police delayed before entering that
classroom when children in the school
were still calling 9-1-1 and panic
parents outside pleaded with them to go
in
to the clamor for answers this admission
from a senior police chief was striking
hey from the benefit of hindsight where
i'm sitting now
that of course it was not the right
decision it was the wrong decision
period there's no no excuse for that
but again i wasn't there but i'm just
telling you from what we know
we believe there should have been an
entry at that as soon as you can hey
when there's an active shooter the rules
change
he was asked how this tragedy had
affected him
you know forget how i'm doing about the
parents
have to do something man for the second
time since the tragedy the governor of
texas was heckled at a news conference
for dismissing guns as the problem the
local democrat senator who did it
explained why
if these people out there in the public
push these guys they need to start
calling his office
and they need to start asking for change
we've also heard from the mother of
gunman salvador ramos
i have no words she says please don't
judge him to the innocent children who
died forgive me
the investigation into her son has
zeroed in on his online life concerns
others had about his guns and even
whether he was planning a school
shooting everyone i have one of his
words
that's his voice in a chat group on the
app ubo we spoke to one young woman who
he was in contact with who he sent
threatening messages to who said his
behavior caused alarm
he was given the nickname hugo's school
shooter and people be like oh hey look
at super school shooter
like
and he never tried to shut down that
nickname like he never
and he seemed almost proud of it you
know like it was
it was just like something that really
could have been prevented
yubo says it's investigating
whatever the warning signs they were
missed so too an opportunity for police
to act all of it leaving them wondering
here whether it could have made the
difference between life and death greg
milam sky news uvalde in texas
just hours away from uvalde and in the
very same states the powerful u.s gun
lobby the national rifle association is
holding its annual convention among the
speakers last night a former president
one donald trump who insisted that
stricter gun laws were not the answer
our u.s correspondent mark stone reports
from houston
for the gun lobby members arriving at
their national convention there is
nothing odd or awkward about the timing
of this event
because there is they believe no
correlation between mass shootings and
guns
guns don't pick themselves up and kill
people it's people that do that he
managed to buy a gun that's right
legally
and walk into a school and shoot 19 kids
the school
was negligent
he shouldn't had the doors open he
walked in an open door do you not think
the gun laws should be tightened
slightly no what they need to do is
enforce the ones they have they're not
doing their job they're letting those
people slip through the cracks
that's the issue you don't think the
issue is too many guns in america no
there are of course nuances some do want
regulation better policing but they all
want their guns can you give us a sense
of why it's important to you
we're a free country
inside guest of honor donald trump read
out the names of the children who died
mckenna
lee
elrod
[Music]
mai tai a mark of respect or deeply
distasteful the former president will
divide opinion as always
sadly before the sun
had even set on the horrible day of
tragedy we witnessed
a now familiar parade of cynical
politicians seeking to exploit the tears
of sobbing families
to increase their own power and take
away our constitutional rights but in
here they are at one the problem isn't
guns it's bad people
if we as a nation
were capable of legislating evil
out of the hearts and minds of criminals
who commit these heinous acts
we would have done it a long time ago
he wouldn't have seen the anti-gun
protests outside bigger and noisier than
even they expected
among them just listen to the views of a
17 year old student who says she is
scared in her classroom every day every
single person in that building right
there is complicit and they are helping
and something needs to be done just
why do you think they're complicit
because if you're not actively doing
something to help the problem you are
part of the problem the star guest here
is the democratic candidate for governor
one time presidential hopeful beto
o'rourke
time for
[Music]
they really do feel as though they have
an energy this time to bring about
meaningful change and however improbable
it may seem they think it could begin in
texas why do you think change will
happen this time
we're committed to it and we're gonna
act
we're gonna break through right now
everyone here is committed to it
but against all this optimism is the
reality a divided ideology that feels
now to be so entrenched if nothing
changed when the country was less
divided how's it really possible now
mark stone sky news in houston
the pressure continues to pile on the pm
in the wake of sue grey's report into
downing street lockdown parties with
another conservative mp submitting a
letter of no confidence in his
leadership
now according to sky news count that
takes the number of tory mps publicly
calling on him to go to 22. boris
johnson also facing criticism after
changes were announced to the
ministerial rule book now ministers will
no longer face the sack if they are
found to have breached it so bob neil
who chairs the justice select committee
said he no longer found the prime
minister's statements to parliament to
be credible
i didn't regard the explanations as
being credible there was a course of
conduct that took place here in number
10 downstream the pattern of behavior
over a number of months which clearly
breached the rules and we can't have a
situation where those who are making the
rules are not adhering to themselves
when they expect everybody else to do so
boris johnson is also facing criticism
after waving through changes to the
ministerial code meaning that those who
breach it will no longer immediately
have to resign or face the sack our
political correspondent liz bates has
the latest
ministerial code in this country is very
much
central to upholding standards in public
life the prime minister is expected to
adhere to it and enforce it and yet at
this moment on the week the sugray
report was released and the behavior of
those at the heart of government has
very much been called into question it's
been watered down now the changes will
mean that breaking the ministerial code
will no longer be considered an
automatic resigning matter and that
minor breaches can be dealt with in
different ways via a reduction in salary
or an apology for example and in
practice that is often
how the code has been uh applied the
problem for the prime minister is that
he is about to be investigated by
the privileges committee who will look
into whether he misled parliament
over the downing street parties now
these changes will not directly affect
that but unsurprisingly uh opposition
mps have jumped on this today and said
that this is him uh changing the rules
ahead of that inquiry trying to get
himself
off the hook the slightly broader
problem will be the perception of this
by the public but also uh by his own mps
many of whom are still very unhappy
about what came out in the sugray report
and are still deciding on how they're
going to react we've heard this week
some of those mps coming out publicly
and saying that they no longer have
confidence in him and that it's time for
him to go it would take 54 letters of no
confidence to trigger a vote of no
confidence in the prime minister and
there will undoubtedly be concern
in downing street that if this drip drip
of letters continues that the prime
minister could very soon find himself in
real trouble
lizbet's there now in a blow to half
term travelers easyjet is cancelling
more than 200 flights
over the next 10 days guys adele
robinson is at gatwick forest good to
see you this morning adele so if we are
heading off via gatwick via easyjet what
are the chances
well there's a lot of anger here amongst
travellers this morning over the late
notice given by easyjet with many
claiming that no viable solutions have
been put forward to save their family
holiday so a huge amount of
disappointment understandably for many
people this would have been their first
opportunity to get away post pandemic
but it's the latest in a catalogue of
chaos that we've seen over the last
couple of days indeed the last few
months seems reminiscent of the easter
chaos at airports when a number of
airlines cancelled many many flights
back then on thursday as you say 200
flights were cancelled by easyjet due to
i.t issues yesterday we saw queues of up
to three hours leading into the port of
dover as travellers tried to get cross
uh channel today's issues uh today is
announced for yesterday's announcements
rather easyjet cancelling 24 flights a
day over the next 10 days is unrelated
to the it
issues which are said to be resolved
easyjet say that it's down to a range of
issues including air traffic control
restrictions runway works and airport
handling delays
they have apologized in a statement this
is what they've said we're very sorry
for the late notice of some of these
cancellations and inconvenience caused
for customers booked onto these flights
however we believe this is necessary to
provide reliable services over this busy
period customers are being informed from
today which was friday when they
released a statement and provided with
the option to rebook their flight or
receive a refund and can apply for
compensation in line with regulations
but not good enough according to many of
their travelers who question why at
least some of this could not have been
foreseen um it doesn't bode well for the
summer months but it also raises the
question over uh for a travel industry
that appears to be struggling to cope
with demand post pandemic
adele thank you
some of the day's other news now and a
metropolitan police officer has been
charged with raping a woman on brighton
beach while another is being sent for
trial accused of 21 counts of rape over
17 years
sergeant lawrence knights was arrested
in july last year after a woman reported
being raped on the beach 11 days earlier
he will now appear at brighton and hove
magistrates court in june
a second officer attached to met
detention which deals with police
custody units has been suspended from
duty
the jury in the defamation trial between
johnny depp and amber heart has been
sent out to consider its verdict herds
who claims that debt physically and
sexually assaulted her is being sued by
the hollywood actor for 50 million
dollars over an article she wrote in the
washington post
in which she described herself as a
public figure representing domestic
abuse she is counter-suing her
ex-husband for 100 million dollars after
his lawyer called her allegations a hoax
the uk health security agency has
confirmed that 16 more cases of monkey
pox have been identified in england the
latest cases bring the total number
confirmed since the 7th of may to 101.
there have been three confirmed cases in
scotland one in wales one in northern
ireland taking the uk total to 106. a
statement from uk hsa said the risk to
the uk population remains low
it looks like millions of people are
planning to celebrate the queen's
platinum jubilee with their neighbors
next week it's estimated that around 16
000 street parties will be thrown
with councils having approved a huge
number of applications from residents
across the uk
to the warden ukraine now where
officials are calling on the west for
more to help stop the horrors seen in
the city of mariopol playing out again
across the bombarded donbass region
the governor of luhansk has warned
ukrainian forces may have to retreat
from the last stronghold in the region
to avoid being captured
skies alastair bunker joins us now from
the capital kiev alastair good to see
you this morning explain exactly why
what is happening in the east it is
taking place clearly the russians have
numbers
they do they got the numbers and it is
um strategically geographically about
joining up an area really so if you were
to look at a map uh of the eastern
ukraine with russia to the north and to
the northeast of it um russian forces
have have spread through the eastern
donbass region where of course let's not
forget since uh 2014 there have been
russian separatists there anyway
but they have spread through there and
they are joining up uh various different
regions in the donetsk and luhansk
regions in order to try and create a
corridor between there and some of the
southern port cities like uh mariupol
and then perhaps on to mikhailayev which
has taken a bit of a pounding this
morning and frankly the russians have
the momentum down there
and the final cities that were holding
out against the russians i think
probably will fall if not within days
possibly even within hours now there's
some new satellite imagery that's been
released by the u.s company max our
overnight and it shows russian artillery
and armored vehicle positions in and
around some of the key towns in the
lehansk region so what would happen if
um they do capture the entire hansk well
they will have got a big swathe of the
eastern donbass which
will be um something of a small victory
for for the kremlin for vladimir putin
and we'll see what he would then decide
to do next does he
use it as a platform perhaps for some
sort of negotiations
do they take a strategic pause uh before
moving on and if they do i think what we
would see is they would move south and
west uh through a place like mikulayev
in the hope that they would then
continue progression on to
the port of odessa uh in order to
capture the entire ukrainian seaboard so
it is the the worst fighting is in the
east at the moment and it is where
russia is seeing some progress and the
ukrainians are up against it they are
putting up resistance but as you said in
the introduction to me they are calling
for much more help from nato and the
americans in particular in order to try
and stall that advance
alastair for now thank you
let's quickly run you through the front
pages of the papers starting with the ft
it pictures floral tributes for the 19
children killed in a school shooting in
texas police they are facing growing
anger over the response to the attack
the telegraph it says a conservative mp
son is fighting with ukrainian soldiers
and helps save a fellow britain maimed
by a landmine
the guardian goes with the pm's changes
to the ministerial code which means that
ministers won't need to immediately
resign if caught breaking the rules
triggering accusations the changes were
made to protect his job ahead of a new
inquiry to partygate
the mirror has one of the queen's
platinum jubilee plans set to include
prince charles prince william and prince
george the paper calling them heirs to
the future
the express says that families setting
off for half term holidays face chaos at
airports
and are set for worse this summer due to
staff shortages
and here's the star with the same story
let's return to our top story and the
admission from police in texas that they
made a mistake by not storming the
classroom where a gunman killed 19
children and two of their teachers there
is still a clamor for answers about the
police response after they provided a
full timeline of what happened at rob
elementary school we now have a much
clearer picture of exactly what happened
and when
ramos began his rampage by shooting his
66 year old grandmother on diaz street
at 11 15 am he sends the last of three
private social media messages saying
i'ma go shoot up a elementary school
right now
we know that at 1127 an exterior door to
the school was propped open by a teacher
one minute later ramos crashed his truck
into a ditch near rob elementary school
before getting out of the passenger side
with a rifle and ammunition and moving
towards the school's parking lot
at 11 31 he reaches the last row of cars
in the parking lot and begins shooting
at classrooms
after firing multiple shots at the
school from the car park at 11 33 ramos
enters the school through the now open
door
he walks down the hallway turns right
and begins shooting into classrooms one
one one and one one two
two minutes later three police officers
enter the school through the same door
followed by another four
two suffer minor gunshot wounds
by 1154 parents have started gathering
outside the school a video captures them
confronting the police and urging them
to go in
by midday children could be seen fleeing
the school with law enforcement still
working out how to evacuate those in
sight
at 1203 more officers arrive and go into
the hallway there's as many as 19 in
there now
more shots are heard at 12 21 but it's
not until half an hour later at 12 50
that officers unlocked the door to the
classroom and killed the gunman
and much more response to that admission
from the police here on sky all
throughout the day
now back in 2001 the businessman rick
lewis founded the black heart foundation
with the aim of helping young people
from underrepresented communities
fulfill their potential in education
fast forward to 2013 and the foundation
launched the black heart scholarship
program providing those in need with
funding to access higher education and
now they're celebrating their 500th
scholar adding 400 of them in fact in
less than 18 months fine work uh joining
us now the chairman and of course
founder of the blackheart foundation
rick lewis and one of their scholars
sharon sontan guys lovely to see both of
you and rick i have to start with you
when you set up the black heart
foundation in 2001 did you think a that
it would still be going uh so much later
but that you would now have what 500
scholars
under the black heart foundation's name
it's brilliant well we're actually
pleased and a little bit overwhelmed by
it but yes we set it up with endurance
in mind so that it would go on for a
long time but when we started truly in
2013 we thought we would endow three
scholars per year um the market and
community response to what we're doing
including my board's response and the
huge need that's come from sort of all
of the events of the last few years of
the you know the past of the the global
financial crisis
what's happened in covid and the
coronavirus and how it's just plagued
families and their ability
to have the funds to help their children
and families pursue higher education our
work has become more important so we've
pushed on and now we're at 500 and gonna
go beyond that
um so so rick explain exactly how these
these scholarships are rewarded the
process that people like shawn have to
go through uh to be able to qualify and
what do they get as a result
well let's
tell you how simple it is but really you
turn in you send us a three or four page
uh application which tells us what
you've been doing what your aspiration
uh for program or what you want to do
with your time and then a little bit
about your financial sort of history
sort of what's the cost of the program
what funds resources do you have and
what's the gap and effectively what we
do is we gap fund the difference for
that bursary scholarship or program that
you're pursuing sort of on the pathway
to bigger and better it happens very
rapidly there's two intakes one in the
autumn that's already started now and
runs through the october admissions and
then another one
uh in the early winter for the january
admissions we get back to you very
quickly and we fund the whole gap
between sort of what you can afford and
what that program that you're pursuing
is going to cost
rick no one wants to listen to two
grumpy old men at this time in the
morning so let's bring in shane and i i
i just tell us a little bit about your
your circumstances your situation and
why this scholarship is going to mean so
much to you yeah so good morning um
i was brought up in a single-parent
household with just my mom my brothers
around me and
going through the system obviously it
was a bit difficult trying to
be aspirational knowing that there were
a few barriers to
what i wanted to do and where i wanted
to go so
finding the blackhawk foundation
scholarship was just amazing for me just
because i was able to apply just like
rick said on the application i was just
honest i told him
what i wanted to do what my aspirations
were why there were sort of financial
situations holding me back and
sort of how it would help me and they
really did help me with the gap funding
so that i could really just focus on
what i'm doing now so i'm currently
studying my master's in respiratory
medicine at the university of birmingham
and without the scholarship i genuinely
don't know if i'd still be in the course
it's fantastic and how is that course
going and where do you see yourself
ending up as as a result of all this
[ __ ]
of course are going well course is going
well one year master so i'm going to be
done in september time and
honestly i'm not entirely sure where i'm
going to end up but i know that
regardless of where i end up i'm really
going to be
pushing myself as hard as i can to be
successful because one thing i've always
said to myself and one thing my mom has
always told me and one thing i even said
on the application myself was what's the
point of gathering all this knowledge
and wealth if you can't give back and
that's one thing i really aim to do
myself where i just want to give back to
the community and give back to people
who
find themselves in a similar position to
where i was uh well well done mate
that's a fantastic achievement and rick
i'm sure you're incredibly proud of of
sharon and indeed all the other scholars
if people want to apply how can they do
so
you can find all of our information on
our website at www.blackhat
that's all the details for the
scholarship program is under the
blackrock scholars program it's really
easy and we get back to you pretty
quickly with us once again to review the
papers the journalist and author gemma
forte and the broadcaster afwa hagan and
gemma we're going to start with you
this time inside the mirror page 13 in
fact
the mother of the the school shooter
pleading with the victims to the
families of his victims to forgive him
which i i have to say even in god
feeding texas will be a stretch
completely insensitive i could not
believe it when i read this adriana
reyes the mother of the shooter who's
currently keeping vigil by her mother's
bedside who he because he shot her in
the face first his own grandmother
um the timing is
preposterous these parents who've just
lost their
innocent children will be reeling grief
stricken and quite frankly where do they
focus their anger on you know do they
focus it on these senators who refuse to
tighten up gun laws let alone ban them
outright but now for her to be asking
for forgiveness it seems like a stretch
i'm old enough to remember when stephen
lawrence's mother
came out and forgave his killers but
some time had passed she was a woman of
faith she had had time to process it was
her choice and i think we all admired
her greatly and were really blown away
by her dignity but i for one as a parent
also remember thinking i don't think i
could be that person and if if i had
suffered this right now and then this
woman was asking me to to spare even one
iota of empathy for her son i i just
can't even uh
i can't verbalize how angry i would feel
so i really think she should be keeping
quiet
yeah i suspect we might not be hearing
from her again for for some time and
page 13 of the guardian after i don't
know if you've been following the trial
that the amber heard johnny depp trial i
found myself sitting watching it and
glued to it for a while and then i
realized that i was treating as
entertainment you know some pretty
serious allegations of sexual and and
physical assault
the guardian uh suggesting that gender
relations may well be on trial as well
and i think the guardian could be right
i have been following the amber heard in
johnny depp case and the jury is out
doing their deliberations we are closing
arguments yesterday and you're right
this is a really serious case of an
intimate partner violence of mutual
violence between both parties but what
it seems here when we're talking about
gender relations you know in this case
it seems that in the court of public
opinion at least on social media
johnny depp has won and amber had has
lost
uh when we look at social media for
instance like i talked about
on twitter the hashtag
men2 and johnnydepp have been trending
you know on tick tock at the beginning
of this week the hashtag i stand with
amber heard had 8.2 million views but
the hashtag just justice for johnnydeck
excuse me had 15 billion views and it
seems here that there's so much more
support out there for johnny depp than
there is for amber had now there could
be many reasons behind this because
johnny depp was the one that brought the
case he got to go first he got give his
evidence first and after a few days of
the trial people kind of made up their
own minds that he went first he must be
telling the truth you know there's also
men's rights groups out there
anti-feminist groups online that are
very well organized and very well
organized in their attacking of amber
had and we've seen her being mocked and
memes on saturday night live all across
social media you know people are talking
about um her emotions whether they're
fake or not you know funny moments in
court this is a really really serious
case a really serious case of domestic
violence here and i think yes gender
relations are on trial here as well as
um you know the whole story between the
two of them we've heard so many details
some really grim and gory details of
what's happened in their relationship
and you know who knows what the verdict
will be but i think it really will be a
watershed moment you know amber had had
kind of portrayed herself as the leader
of the metoo movement and johnny depp's
lawyer you know sort of shot that down
and saying it was the me too movement
thanked me too saying that she wasn't a
victim you know we don't know the two of
them really know what happened between
them and it remains to be seen what the
jury will say at the end of their
deliberation yeah and looks like we'll
have to wait a few days for that at the
very least um german let's go inside the
telegraph interesting story this the nhs
is being overloaded by patients who fear
that their rash is monkey pox i've seen
some pictures of the reaction to monkey
pox so these people's rashes must be
pretty gory
absolutely i looked at the first
pictures of monkey pox and thought no
thank you that is not a good look and
i'm only making light because nobody has
died of monkey blocks yet i think it's
really important to stress that um we
also it's a member of the same family of
viruses as smallpox so we have vaccines
already equipped to deal with this so
there are some positives within this
revolting new virus that is spreading
about i think there's 90 cases in the uk
so far but i think understandably
there's a lot of post covered hysteria
um and people are wanting to get checked
out and that is their right to go and
make sure that what they've got isn't
this thing but they are getting
completely overloaded i mean this kind
of conflates with another story in the
mail actually that there are so many
people not being able to get a gp
appointment at the moment that a lot of
people are going private for the first
time and then at the root of all that
you're looking at burnout you're looking
at staff shortages so for the nhs as
well this monkey box timing is just
absolutely abysmal
um i wonder if we can jump actually to
your last story it's the front of the
mirror and it took me a while to get the
pun in the headline heirs to the future
here's to the future yeah i got it now
but this is this is all about the men in
the royal family and uh what they'll be
doing come the jubilee
yes so this is um kind of definitely
about the platinum jubilee it's about
that balcony moment at 5pm on sunday
after um the the jubilee pageant that
will be taking place and you know
there's been lots of talk about who will
be on the balcony and who won't and it
seems that the queen is going to be on
the balcony with charles with william
and prince george uh she wants to have a
short of them all together and this is
the kind of to show the world what is to
come in the royal family that this is
the future of the royal family and these
are the arrows to the future and the
heirs of the thorn like you said and and
you know lots to be made about this
particular balcony moment because megan
and harry won't be there she said it's
only for royals which i think is
absolutely fair enough because it's the
queen's platinum jubilee she should
absolutely be able to decide you know
what happens on that day but i think
what the queen is doing with this is
really giving giving us up for the
future what the future of the royal
family will look like when unfortunately
she is not around and the future is uh
these three men as prince charles is
prince william and prince george so
that's sort of the pinnacle of the
four-day jubilee weekend and that's
going to end with pr ed sheeran singing
to the queen in front of the balcony so
why not